so this is a super interesting story
that is getting a lot of attention in
the last 24 hours I was even on rising
this morning talking about this with
crystal ball and cigar and jetty and the
story is that House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
of course a Democrat said yesterday that
she would be comfortable with Bernie
Sanders as the Democratic presidential
nominee if indeed he ends up being the
selection of the Democratic primary
voters in what's left of this 2020
Democratic primary and she was asked
this just as she was walking out of a
meeting of the House of Representatives
and she simply said yes answering the
question yes she would be comfortable
and this is interesting for a few
different reasons and before we go on
with the discussion also note that
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer was
asked a similar question and he sort of
seemed to be saying the same thing he
said quote look the bottom line is very
simple we have a lot of strong nominees
and I'm not supporting one over the
other but I think every one of them will
be will beat President Trump or would be
better than President Trump so not a
ringing endorsement but certainly both
Schumer and Pelosi the Democratic
leaders in the respective House Senate
and House are saying they would at least
be okay with a Bernie Sanders nomination
so there's a few different angles here
to talk about first of all is okay I
mean they recognize that Bernie of all
the candidates has the clearest path to
the nomination it's certainly clearer
than any other individual candidate
right now and so they're just getting in
line this is a relatively cynical
interpretation but I think one that is
not a irrationally cynical they want to
be on the inside not the outside if
Bernie Sanders ends up as the nominee
and in particular if Bernie Sanders ends
up being president so in one sense you
could say we don't really have to pay
much attention to Pelosi and Schumer
saying this because it is a cynical
strategic decision of the centrist
establishment Democrats to make sure
that they don't end up getting the door
shut on them if Bernie Sanders becomes
nominee or president and that's
obviously part of it there is no
question that they don't want to be on
the outside if Bernie's the nominee but
there's a very important secondary
in here if you look at the 538 odds
right now there are roughly equal odds
of Bernie securing the nomination before
the DNC with 1991 delegates or more and
roughly equal odds of there being nobody
who gets to 50% plus one if there is
nobody who gets to 50% plus one
delegates before the DNC the Democratic
establishment is going to need to decide
whether they want to contest the
convention and try to deny Bernie
Sanders the nomination either through
the Alliance of the delegates of various
centrist candidates or with the addition
of the super-delegates on the second
round of voting who could just hand the
nomination to somebody else so the
importance of Nancy Pelosi and Schumer
signaling we're at least okay with a
Bernie nomination maybe a sign that the
Democratic establishment is not going to
try to contest or broker the convention
in order to deny Bernie the nomination
even if he has a plurality of the
delegates that in and of itself is a
crucial decision because that could have
a huge effect on the general election it
is conceivable that if the Democratic
Party is seen as heavy-handed and going
out of their way to deny the nomination
to the person with the most delegates if
that person is indeed Bernie Sanders
there is a risk that that is going to
reduce turnout in November and help
Donald Trump win it is a risk that it
will turn some Democratic voters who
support Bernie Sanders in the primary
away from voting at all in November or
even towards writing somebody in third
party to voting for Donald Trump even
and when you start to see party leaders
saying things like Nancy Pelosi saying
I'd be comfortable with Bernie as the
nominee this could be a very important
sign that they recognize that it could
be a self-destructive action to take the
nomination from Bernie Sanders or to be
seen as doing that even if it's not in
practice what you believe is going on
now at the same time could it this could
be something that is being said by
Pelosi and Schumer to make us think they
won't contest the convention when in
fact they plan to but that's sort of
like to layer
of cynicism maybe it's too much cynicism
there's also a potential lesson here
from Republicans in 2016 because when
you think back to the Republican primary
in 2016
remember that for a whole bunch of that
primary the full Republican
establishment including Fox News and a
lot of right-wing media they were united
against Donald Trump instead of with
Donald Trump
now they ultimately came around to him
because anything was better than Hillary
in their eyes and Donald Trump ended out
just barely squeaking out an electoral
college victory because of about 77,000
votes in three key states it's not crazy
to think that if the DNC were to simply
rally behind whoever is the nominee and
even behind whoever is looking like they
have the best shot at being the nominee
which right now is Bernie they might be
saying even if we don't like Bernie even
if we're not actually comfortable with
Bernie as the nominee if Republicans
were able to get Trump elected even
after being against them almost all the
primary and coming to him at the end may
be our best shot at removing Trump is
just getting behind whoever is the
nominee regardless of whether they are
from what they perceive to be a
different wing of the left or the
Democratic Party in the end it's
important that Nancy Pelosi is even
willing to say this at this point in
time even if it's completely cynical
even if it's completely self-serving and
out of her motivation not to end up on
the outside of the Democratic Party if
indeed Bernie Sanders becomes the
nominee or president it is still
important that she's saying this at this
point in time if you have a different
interpretation of what Pelosi and
Schumer signaling at least acquiescing
to the idea of a Bernie Sanders
candidacy let me know I do want to hear
from you